la cre avait nettoyé tapella bitches
dehors n'y a rien d'intéressant je suis
là depuis toujours et j'ai l'impression
que j'irai jamais ce que je fais tous
les matins
ensuite j'ai apporté des jeunes et à ma
mère a déjà lu page et dort profondément
graal tout le temps bon tu montes
mais ce qu'on dit non il ya trop de fric
sur la route il va à présent pourquoi
les partis ça tu veux en venir ou là
du tout
purement prénatal émergent imaginait des
ordres des mois quel sera son sort et à
laquelle pensent que s'amuse avec les
copains
notez djékou c'est tout mais bien sûr
l'état fou
ça a duré cinq minutes
à table je vais pas rentrer dans ce
petit jeu vous rendez compte que vous
mais qu'est ce que je t'ai vu bordel
non
ma femme est là
une attention